Noelle is on Twitter you can follow me
there at Dave Ramsey what's the best way
to get out of a car lease god I hate
those things
they're just it's just you're just stuck
you're just stuck in a mud hole well
there's really only one well other than
pay it out or wait it out or something
like that there's really only one way to
get out and it's basically selling a car
that you owe more on than it's worth and
car people call that being upside down
in the car and so you could call the we
call them fleeces because you're a sheep
that's being fleeced bad idea okay
now oh god had to get that out of my
system but anyway so you call the fleece
company whoever you fleets to the car
from and you ask them what the early
block by out on your fleece is and the
early buy out consists of your actual
financial exposure today is the the
residual value that you can buy the car
for at the end of the lease stated in
your contract on a closed-end lease and
that's about all that's out there
anymore
some of the other junk got running out
of the market several years back so
you're going to have a residual value
that you buy the car for at the end of
the lease then you've got your monthly
lease payments and if your monthly lease
payments three hundred ninety three
dollars and you have 20 months left then
you got what is that seven thousand
bucks or so eight thousand bucks that
you got in payments left plus your
residual value is twelve thousand then
you've got twenty thousand dollars in
financial exposure you can add those two
figures together now you're early buy
out will be somewhat not much but
somewhat less than that total figure
because you're paying it off early you
don't have what is called cost of
capital in a lease but it's basically
your interest they're not going to
charge you interest because you're
paying it off twenty months early and so
instead of twenty thousand it might be
I'll make up a number eighteen thousand
and so if you call and on this mythical
car I just described and you have a an
$18,000 early buyout and you find the
car to be worth private sale on Kelley
Blue Book fifteen thousand dollars then
you owe eighteen it's worth fifteen year
three thousand dollars up
i down uo 18 it's worth 15 so how are we
going to get rid of this car well you
put it in Craigslist for sale for
$15,000 someone comes to you to buy it
in order for you to get the title
they're going to give you 15 but you got
to have that other three and so you need
to have arranged a loan for the
difference that you're in the hole and
go to your local credit union your local
bank and say I've got a $3,000 personal
loan and you get a personal loan for
3,000 bucks you put that with the
$15,000 that your Craigslist buyer gives
you that is 18 you send the 18 to the
fleece company they send you the title
you give it to your buyer it works the
same way if you just have a simple car
loan that you owe more on your car then
it's worth but you just have to go
through more crap with the leases and
you're going to find yourself further in
the hole because they suck even worse
than car payments why do people do
leases because we live in a culture that
quit asking how much they now ask how
much down and how much a month and the
car fleece is less down in less a month
than the traditional car payment you can
drive the car off the lot
with less out of pocket today and less
monthly out of pocket but folks you ever
heard the saying pay me now or pay me
later
you're going to pay them later they're
sticking it to you the cost of capital
which is the interest rate you're paying
is not disclosed you know why this is
technically not alone so it doesn't a
Federal Trade Commission disclosure
rules on loans don't apply you know
anytime you borrow money they have to
give you all this paperwork that shows
you exactly what your interest rate is
what your APR is and what all the costs
are and all this crap you get all these
pieces of paper when you're borrowing
money that the federal government makes
them give you to say they're ripping you
off and show you clearly how they're
doing it with a car lease they don't
even have to tell you that you don't get
a full disclosure you don't know what
your cost of capital is and so you could
be paying an 18% interest rate or a 14%
interest rate and by the way you likely
are Consumer Reports Smart Money
Magazine Dave Ramsey and my calculator
all say leases are the most expensive
to operate a vehicle do not lease a car
well rich people do well not not people
that want to be rich long and rich
people don't buy the way rich people all
the studies tell us that rich people
what they do is they buy depending on
how rich they are but if they're wealthy
like a million dollars worth of wealthy
or less but they're out of debt kind of
people they buy a two-year old or older
car now people who make twenty million
dollars may buy a new Maserati I don't
know right or they may buy a new
whatever Lamborghini or something but
that's not what I'm talking about but
but the typical millionaire is driving a
two-year-old or older car that they paid
cash for now not the fifty millionaire
and not the hundred millionaire but the
typical millionaire they're driving a
two-year-old car that they paid cash for
because they figured out the car
payments or a freaking ripoff that it's
the mantra the motto of the middle-class
where you're always going to have a car
payment you're always going to have a
car payment so you might as well have a
small car payment get the car lease even
though we're completely freakin selling
our Fant financial soul in the process
our future but by god we got a car that
everybody's impressed with why because
we could press hard as we sign our name
there's three copies so make sure your
name goes on to all the copies that's
the ripoff car leasing is the worst way
to purchase or maintain or own or have a
car in your driveway bar none
no exceptions so I just made all you
little new car dealers mad and you'll
just have to get over it
it's the worst way to buy a car never
have a car payment if you want to win
with money never have a car payment if
you want to win with money the average
car payment North America today is four
hundred eighty six dollars over eighty
two months according to the National
Auto Dealers Association that's five
hundred bucks a month hello if you take
that five hundred
a month and you put it in a cookie jar
for ten months you have $5,000 drive
what you're driving and save up and pay
cash for your car if you can't save up
and pay cash for your car that means you
can't afford the car because you think
you can pay the payments that does not
mean you can afford it I can afford it
usually means I think I can squeeze this
in because I really want this bad and
I'm a four-year-old emotionally and I
can't tell myself no rich people ask how
much poor people and broke people ask
how much down how much a month this is
the Dave Ramsey show
you